Мітингувальники у Мінську зводять барикади
зі сміттєвих контейнерів та всього, що є під руками.
Хтось навіть притягнув величезний килим...
Шості президентські вибори в історії новітньої Білорусі
стали найбільш напруженими та безпрецедентними
за рівнем жорстокості розгону акцій протесту, стверджують оглядачі.
У Євросоюзі одразу ж засудли непропорційне і неприйнятне насильство
проти мирних демонстрантів і заговорили про можливість нових санкцій проти Мінська.
Через жорстке придушення протестів після виборів 2010 року
Захід вже запроваджував санкції проти Лукашенка та його оточення.
Але через шість років їх зняли
Тепер з огляду на репресії під час передвиборчої кампанії
та жорстке придушення акцій протесту після виборів
заклики до нових штрафних заходів лунають дедалі частіше
Одним з перших про це заговорив офіційний Берлін.
Хочу нагадати, що ЄС зняв санкції з Білорусі,
тому що країна зробила кроки в правильному напрямку.
Йшлося, приміром, про звільнення політв'язнів.
Тепер ми в ЄС, звичайно ж, маємо обговорити,
чи може це залишатися в силі
в світлі подій минулого тижня і минулих днів.
Під посольством Білорусі в Берліні білоруська діаспора
та молодіжний підрозділ Вільної демократичної партії ФРН
провели акцію протесту з вимогою відставки Лукашенка
та проведення вільних виборів у Білорусі.
В акції протесту взяв участь і лідер "вільних демократів" Крістіан Лінднер.
Має бути чітко і ясно заявлено, що фальсифікація виборів абсолютно неприйнятна.
І що врешті-решт подібний політичний режим не може вважатися легітимним.
З цим режимом не можна сідати за один стіл, не можна вести переговори
ані про питання зовнішньої торгівлі, ані про щось інше.
Потрібно насамперед вести мову про демократію і права людини,
не можна переходити до звичного порядку денного, наче нічого не трапилося.
Лукашенко зберіг владу, але втратив країну, пишуть німецькі ЗМІ.
Майбутня очільниця проектів щодо Росії та Центральної Азії
німецького фонду Фрідріха Науманна
намагається оговтатися після того, що творилося в Мінську
та інших білоруських містах після закриття виборчих дільниць.
Нечувана жорстокість - це сигнал того, що дні Лукашенка
на посаді президента вже злічені, вважає вона.
На цих виборах Лукашенко втратив усю свою легітимність:
як усередині країни, так і за кордоном, як на Заході, так і на Сході.
Крім того, опозиція вперше об'єдналася.
І чітко сказала, що так більше тривати не може.
Думаю, що тепер почнеться фаза політичної кризи,
і її наслідки неможливо передбачити
Але в будь-якому випадку ці вибори не залишаться без наслідків.
За словами німецької експертки, головна відмінність нинішніх виборів -
відчайдушна самовідданість громадян
і чітко виражений запит на зміни в економіці та політиці.
Білоруський народ сказав: досить!
У Лукашенка було 26 років часу,
а країна в перманентній економічній кризі,
плюс нестабільна зовнішня політика, стагнація,
відсутні структурні реформи як в економічній сфері, так і в суспільно-політичній.
І при цьому - дуже талановитий народ,
який не може розкритися за цих умов.
Багато хто виїхав з країни.
У Білорусі величезні можливості, які не можуть бути реалізовані.
У берлінському відділенні Німецького фонду Маршалла
поділяють думку про те, що розпочався політичний крах Лукашенка.
Це початок кінця, але ми не знаємо, як довго це триватиме.
Можливо, що Лукашенко припинить бути президентом
вже протягом декількох днів
Але можливо і те, що він відновить контроль над ситуацією,
яка склалася зараз, з усією жорстокістю, на яку він здатний.
І потім він як ослаблений президент залишиться на посаді.
Ослаблений, оскільки, з одного боку, він знає,
наскільки слабка його підтримка серед населення,
тобто йому доведеться встановлювати повну диктатуру.
А з іншого боку - він буде отримувати дедалі менше підтримки ззовні.
Останні події на вулицях білоруських міст шокували німецьких експертів.
Вони вважають, що 26-річна ера
Лукашенка добігає кінця
і це лише питання часу.